we were rocking man we were out we were
out there rocking i don't know if you
heard the uh the first third down for
the
for the texans man but um they couldn't
even they couldn't even communicate out
there we only had
20 percent of the the stadium filled up
man it was awesome
i think we have the the confidence in
every single person that's in that hole
that they can make plays happen when
their number is called that was brutal
yeah i didn't do very good with that
thing but listen it
it will be better the next time so i
appreciate you asking that though it was
a bit of a mess but
we'll get it fixed
football is back and last night's game
looked a lot like a normal football game
depending upon what camera angles just
saw chris the images of the field
itself during the games
it's football exactly but it'd be the
it's the sideline shots where
all of the masks you see and andy reed
with his face shield that was
badly in need of a windshield wipe oh my
gosh something
or someone to reach up under and put a
smiley face on it's something you can't
do that again trying out
it was crying out for someone to just
just just the mouth
two dots that's it that's all it needed
can they get a windshield wiper on that
they don't have one of those shields
with like a mechanical windshield wiper
on that but i
i felt for him i mean it was humid and
rainy and whatever else and he's sitting
there trying to look at the game on the
field and look at his play sheet
and do all that he couldn't see crap out
there so yeah he's gonna have to
reassess that plan
and i think uh travis kelsey should
reassess his plan for
coat i'm not sure if i like that i'm not
quite sure what that was
but you know what i'll agree with travis
kelsey the game sounded like any other
game
it did and 16 000 fans in the stands can
create
noise that is similar not nearly as
deafening
as a full stadium but it did
sound normal and it looked normal as
long as the shots
were only of the field it looked like
the second half of a pre-season game
whenever we would see the crowd because
that's the thing i think some people
thought okay there's 16 000 they're all
going to be in the lower bowl no
in order to properly distance you've got
16 000
everywhere throughout the stadium it
just looks like a very sparse crowd
yeah no it does it's uh it's an odd look
there's no doubt about that the chiefs
fans though
as we expected uh they made it sound
like there was twice as many people in
the stadium but it
overall you know even though it was
you're right
certain camera angles the crowd noise it
all seemed
normal but it still wasn't there was
something missing a little bit
like you know it's still weird like you
said see the crowd
see that i felt like the players early
on
were you know trying to figure out their
emotions in the moment too
you know of course we had all the
pre-game stuff and all that but
i bet it was weird for them to run out
on a stadium and be like you know
whether you're used to getting booed or
getting the crowd going you're going
wait this is weird this is just not the
same
environment and i felt early on that
kind of showed where they were kind of
getting used to the environment used to
another team of course
and uh it's just a different way of
football for right now but
like we've seen in the nba and
everything else i think they'll grow
accustomed to it and we won't miss a
beat
and the thing is some games with fans in
the stands most games with none in the
stand so it's going to be a different
adjustment
as you get used to if you're the texans
and chiefs being in a stadium with 16
000 next game potentially zero depending
upon who plays where but most of the
games will be played without fans at all
and with that
background noise that your friend kyle
shanahan calls a form of human torture
of 70 to 75 decibels that never
modulates that never turns off that
never
changes it's always there always always
always how is that why is that i don't
understand that like
we can we don't have anybody that can
press a button or turn the volume down
during a commercial break or at a dead
moment of the game
that doesn't make sense to me i i don't
know i mean i guess it's just
is it just as easy as that we'll leave
it there don't mess with it and
they don't want to do that i don't i
don't get that one i mean to the extent
that they are
concerned about overall equity and
fairness the best thing to do is set it
at the same level
the entire time i don't get it because
the thing is
they have noise of the crowd that is
curated for the broadcast
right so it's going to come through the
sound is going to come through and it's
been meticulously selected based upon
circumstances of games played in that
stadium it's going to sound at home like
a normal game
in that stadium would sound even though
no one's gonna be there so i don't know
why you even need
the background noise i don't know what
the point of it is
uh other than to other than to to keep
it from being so
quiet and so easy to hear everything
that's said
that i don't know maybe you have some i
don't know i don't know
i'm trying i'm grasping at yeah to come
up with a reason why
there's this compulsion to have what is
by all appearances and based on everyone
who's dealt with it a very annoying
and unnecessary element when you're
trying to go about your business
yeah no you're right i mean we'll we'll
see how that plays out too
i could see how you can be frustrated
with that it's going to change how you
communicate on the sidelines
and everything like that during dead
moments gonna be hard to have those
conversations where
hey defensive staff let's get together
on the headsets here and
have a little conversation if it's the
noise is where it is it sounds like that
could uh
throw a wrench into things but uh
hopefully this stuff
can be changed a little bit as we go too
i would hope that the nfl would
all right this is annoying our teams it
doesn't make sense it's not great for
the broadcast and things like that
let's have somebody there to turn the
volume up or down or just to adjust to
whatever makes the product the best i i
hope the nfl is willing to do that
i've never gotten a good explanation on
why they're going to do it now you've
got me curious i'm going to make the
request today we'll see if they get on
the case
why are they doing yeah go do your job
why are they doing it
i think that's a fair question but when
the game began and i agree with you it
just i think it was weird for everyone
yeah definitely strange to see nfl
football it was strange to see something
look so
normal again from the shots of the field
itself during the game play
something so normal that that we don't
expect
any normalcy to to come through our tv
especially when it comes to football so
it was it was heartwarming it was
familiar
it was comforting and it did take a
little time to get things rolling
although at the end of the day you know
the chiefs last night looked a lot like
the chiefs that you think they could be
this year
where they just dismantle everybody yes
uh i i feel like we watched it
at least a game last night where one
team was on a different level than the
other
i mean in all capacities i really do
mean that you know first off the talent
on the football field
i think that showed i mean the chiefs
have so many playmakers on both sides of
the ball
then i think the next round i looked at
that jumped out to me
the array and variety of plays
that you see kansas city run as compared
to houston
where there's just so many different
ways and tricks and formations and
oh we found all this is window dressing
to isolate travis kelsey one on one and
he'll make a move and it's really the
play is all about him and kelsey will
i mean and mahomes will hit him same
thing on the defensive side of the ball
you know houston looked like they played
just basic conservative
especially after the first series or two
and there steve spagnolo and honey
badger
and frank clark i mean they're moving
around and changing defenses
and doing all kinds of crazy coverages
so you know when i just look at it like
that i looked at a team last night that
was
yeah on another level another playing
field right now from the houston texans
and yeah i think the chiefs can be
special
we communicated about some of this
during the game last night but you got
the sense as did i that the texans
instead of deliberately slowing it down
on offense only
deliberately slowing it down defensively
taking away
the deep stuff right and forcing the
chiefs to be methodical
the problem is sometimes when you force
an offense to be methodical
it is and it gasses your defense exactly
you know
sometimes they're methodical too and
they methodically drive the ball down
your throat on a 16 play drive for a
touchdown or
something like that but yeah mike i mean
i think that's something that jumped out
to me during the game
houston seemed so scared of letting up
that big play
doing something like that that they were
almost willing to die a slow
death and i think ever since mexico city
last year the chiefs playing the
chargers out there
that was the changing point for me for
the kansas city offense i think that's
when they realized wait
we got to come up with more plays and
more ways if teams want to play these
deep zones
and take away all these deep shots then
we got to find ways to just expose them
underneath
and i feel like their variety of offense
and everything
they have grew from that point to where
you saw last night now with clyde
edwards elaire
and all the stuff andy's figured out and
drawn up in the sand and whatever else
that
you're gonna have a hard time playing
that approach against them too you're
gonna
because they find out they've they know
how to be surgical now and go okay we'll
go 12 plays 80 yards boom boom boom
no big deal and i think that might have
to make some teams reassess how they uh
attack kansas city as well and that was
a big part of the transition patrick
mahomes had to make last year and he
told us before the season that that is
where
he needed to grow not looking for the
kill shot
right taking what's available and see
that's the thing
okay fine the defense did what it needed
to do keep everything in front of it
something rodney harrison advocates
and then what what what happened what do
you have to show for you say
fine right did she say fine we'll do it
you're going to force us to keep
everything in front of you we will and
you won't be able to stop us
and it's amazing to me to see the split
between
run and pass for an andy reed team right
when you've got
33 drop backs and 34 rushing attacks
i gotta have more writing attempts than
passing attempts if you include the one
sack
that patrick holmes had he had 33
dropbacks
and 34 rushing attempts hi
i'm mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports